раз ми себе 5 уроків там акули ви
стала кінці кімнату вино вниз волосіні в
росію було одні з ваших головних сил
загляду на нинішню гризуни була
допущена по malkova
я знайди поважаю ще таке коло buff
правильним я досі ікон ще
збагатив сферах у нас спині інтереси
червоним пішов кудись ват ще російських і
сенсу не виділяється нашого попрут
ще у 2010 році ми ви вирішили накладати
випорожнювати те особисте партнерство між
натомість і росією кремль поводити особливий
ок партнер російських ризиковий документ
ми бачимо що росіян і до з'являтися на
ту й вікна ворога та всі штати ягода ще
за промінь від Росії було правильно
ми по ви не 1 курс відомі ти ще росія
та й вийти на сцені наші
це видно на цілі гуго ти дуже і чуття
нову ситуацію за успіху Європи я б ви
знали вала сьогодні роль vrucica
стратегічний партнер чиї нові старий
купа тиску dab від музику мразі з не
партнер російських доктор енн
ще росія 1 синя нас як ворога 1990
всім уроку мис кликав і роду росія-нато
накиди молодість ще не даю мазь 1 на 1
вояка на вороги і не за 100 свого сина.
про ти 1-го лдпр на прикладі україни
baci мощі росії відкрито по рушниці і все
ті основоположник принципи думаю ще розуму
буде йому нам потрібно все про сенс ти
йди і 1000 до Росії з позиції сили та
ад втоми вони адже шклові експерта
називаю diy русей в україні гібридну
виною складати вираз що нато
виявився на підготовленому до такого
нового способу вода не вини шуму of core
випадково toupper ми стали розум нижчими
чоловік вигнуті для нас з'явилася на спаді
він якусь ще росію порушив усе
фундаментальні принципи раді росія
нато і свої міжнародні забави в'язання
ми дуже коли видосе ще одна по вожатий
основні принципи впала США стане 20
рокки ми виходимо з товщі Росії
розділяючи інакше зашкодить у сунна овочі
нам по трибун ви значний міжнародний
порядок і в порядку wanna система б
спати і тепер ми бачимо що вони до
є нація інакше він же і ми по ви не
відравати на таку нову ситуацію
генеральний секретар натомість андерс фог
розмусний дикою ми відразу чи стійка
wacom